little disclaimer in this episode there
will be some drug talk
um
spicy yeah some spicy drug talk so if
dooley warned if you or anyone around
you is sensitive to that kind of stuff
maybe skip this one but if you like that
stuff then oh
buckle up you're in for a treat
[Music]
so a couple years ago i had the
opportunity to smoke some marijuana with
none other than snoop dogg
snoop dogg yes uh snoop dog sorry snoop
doggy dog we were doing a uh a game show
called to tell the truth we had been
laughing and stuff together and we
really hit it off on the show
he was like hey man hey you wanna you
wanna hit some uh i forget how he said
he said in a much cooler probably cooler
than that yeah you wanna hit some reefer
he said the opposite of that i forget
how he invited me back to his trailer to
smoke and um and i didn't and i to this
day i regret it yeah well i think it was
it was both really professional of you
and really lame yeah yeah it was it was
both it's a professional and lame
move yes
you're listening to life is short i'm
your host justin long
life could be a dream
[Music]
with me as always is my um
uh opt more optimistic
co-host right now i am yeah so you would
what would you have done would you have
cause i i i think i like um dismiss this
i
i did have to do another taping of the
show that's a crucial part of the story
yeah and you have to really use your
mind for this
i wouldn't even think i think you
absolutely did the right thing i was
just knowing you knowing
what you know how you could be affected
by such a substance especially i think
some people can do it obviously snoop
can do it i think snoop is
more comfortable probably and
like a better version of himself even in
like a public forum well he was
definitely when he stoned yeah yeah but
his i also think his tolerance must be
and i smoke a fair amount but i think
his tolerance must be through the roof
so if i had just because i've uh
encountered this with other people who
are
notable weed users i've i've those that
i've gotten to smoke with just this
tiniest bit goes
a long way yeah but it's also you're
naturally a more neurotic person than a
lot of these people so you think then
snoop
so to be on camera like that it it
doesn't seem worth it at all i know i
know it'd be a cool opportunity but and
there's no way you could have like made
a plan for later with him
um to take a rain check with snoop i
guess there is a way i could have done
that i didn't know how to do it it would
have been it would have been hard to do
that in a cool way like not that no no
take it would you take a race
i told you once i was driving down
sunset and this car cut me off um
coming out of a jack-in-the-box or or i
think it was jackman what it doesn't
matter and it was going so slow in front
of me this big escalade this like tinted
window escalade and i was like kind of i
don't know if i beeped at it but i was
annoyed by it and it slowly drifted into
the the other lane that i couldn't get
to do it cut off another car to get into
the left lane and so now we're uh i
pulled up next to it at a red light and
i rolled my down my window to like say
something
it was back when i got um
my road rage would become like star road
sarcasm and be like oh great job you
know we're like
good so i rolled down my window and
their window rolled down i guess they
saw me looking at them they could tell i
wanted to say something it was just like
and as it rolled smoke just started
billowing out of the windows
and it rolled down and snoop
oh it's your second opportunity yeah
yeah a third and then we met with kat at
some talk show we have a picture with
him
by the way he wouldn't remember any of
these for sure
no it's just like meeting like a generic
a guy who decided not to smoke weed with
him oh yeah well maybe that's what he
remembers maybe he's like somebody
turned me this that guy turned me down
to smoke with me
why are we talking about snoop good
question
well snoop is of course
as we're saying a very notorious weed
user is that lame
i don't know how to talk about smoking
notorious i don't know how to talk about
it in a cool way how do you say it he
smokes he smokes he smokes herb
[Music]
he's pokes the conch he's hit the the
pipe from time to time no he's smoke
spot he's famous yeah for being a great
musician but he's also famous for
being uh we don't know why he is a great
musician i don't know why it's funny to
call snoop a great musician well you
think of like mozart yes yes like
a great musician but he is you know what
cause i stopped myself i almost said
rapper oh that would sound nerdy it
would
he is a hell of a rapper
but uh yes he's a great musician and um
known for uh his enjoyment of
the
mary jane you know who else is a
great artist
and famous weed smoker in our culture
noise our guest today that's right
that's right now who's our guest today
we're really laboring this point because
we're so excited to have him
uh he's definitely not listening don't
you think what are the odds that he's
listening he might be
matthew mcconaughey all right i mean he
must be you know i was gonna like do i
think everyone's sick of the uh right
all right not sick of it but like
it's enough already
but we talk about it well you just did
it
did it yeah it's enough already starting
next now okay all right now starting now
um yeah he is somebody that we have been
uh huge fans of since we were
teenagers back uh in 1993 or 1994
when days confused came out i remember i
was
you showed it to me
and i was in eighth grade
and um
if you haven't seen the movie it's about
the last day of school in
1976. if you haven't seen the movie you
should not be listening to this now you
should just watch it yeah but uh
basically it's about um last day of
school in this in this texas yeah 1976
man uh and i was in eighth grade when i
saw the movie so i
for some reason was convinced that
my
eighth grade like end of eighth grade
going into high school experience was
gonna be like was gonna be like that
might go to this really great keg party
in the woods with beautiful older girls
would be there michelle burke would be
there joey lauren adams would be there
and uh you'd have to avoid nikki cat
needless to say
that's not what happened to me yeah
speaking of somebody's token some reefer
yeah you know like adam goldberg yeah
and tastes confused you know that's not
a bad question we entertain i mean that
movie is so seminal for us that's such
uh i think it's it's difficult to
overstate how important that movie was
to our to our
youth
um but didn't we to the point where we
played with the idea of asking somebody
who their which character they
identified with the most in that movie
um
who would it be for you i i mean i guess
it would be adam's rap
yeah yeah i had a dream last night
yeah a lincoln dream he's great in that
everybody's great in it
i love that movie so much i mean it's
well it's his first movie it's
mcconaughey's first movie and then
everyone knows what happened after that
he became
a huge huge star and now he has
a book out it's a memoir he wrote from
um
for the last about the last 50 years of
his life basically it's green lights
called green lights green lights and
justin and i listened to it um on the
way up to visit our grandma jody uh fans
the show will such different people such
different people but both really cool
yeah yeah and now both uh connected
because they've both been guests of the
show that's right uh we drove up to see
her with we drove our mom up to see her
mom our grandma and my mother had this
image of matthew mcconaughey that maybe
a lot of other people have i don't want
to say her generation and be ageist but
that she thought of him as like
you know kind of um
a cartoonish figure public figure like
he was uh cool and a weed smoker but i
think she she had no idea that he was
capable of um such
wit and
storytelling charm and he really won her
over he sure did and you know what we
should do is play because i recorded my
mom's reaction to the book yeah oh she's
going to love that we should play it at
the end
of the episode as a voice memo but yeah
he won her over and he um he cemented uh
my own
perception of him which was already one
of a steam
um but i i see him in it in a different
way now i really uh
anyway you'll hear me gush i i won't do
more of that
now at the top of the show cause you'll
get plenty of it but god it's a hell of
a book it's a really fun and i would
recommend listening to it um because you
get the performance yeah it's a great
performance and he does and we talk
about this he has such good voices such
good uh it's ironic that so many people
do an impression of him
um
it's the one thing that i ever did on
saturday night live is an impression of
him i didn't tell him that anyway we'll
talk about maybe for the best yeah
definitely for the best
proud of myself for uh holding back that
spicy information um anyway let's let's
get on with it
we have like one one of the um the
coolest guess right let's hear from him
all right here he is the one and only
texas zone
matthew mcconaughey all right
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wandery plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
christmas tis the season to deck the
halls and exchange presents with loved
ones but over the past decade a new
tradition has emerged binge-watching
low-budget made-for-tv holiday movies
the all-new podcast series business wars
christmas movie wars looks at how
christmas films started creating massive
profits and how the battle to have the
highest rated christmas movies has
become an intense christmas tradition in
2009 the hallmark channel aired
wall-to-wall holiday programming from
thanksgiving to christmas surprisingly
it was a ratings bonanza and rocketed
the little watch channel to number one
hallmark's competitor lifetime took note
and launched their own block of
christmas movies this sparked a rivalry
that has lasted almost a decade and then
netflix started making christmas movies
and what started as a business
competition turned into an all-out
battle for viewers attention listen to
business wars christmas movie wars on
amazon music apple podcast or you can
listen early and add free by joining
wondering plus in the wondery app
hello hello again
[Music]
your whole background looks so you look
so official this is so great
what do you got there where where are
you i'm in austin texas oh i got a mic
look at that there's american i got i
got a country i love that need we need
to all start thinking about how we're
going to tend to this situation well i
would say the first step would be to
read this there's some great um the the
quote that jumps out is um
uh before you
before you indict you gotta educate i'm
getting that a little wrong but that's
one that really yeah educate before you
indict yeah yeah um there's so many
great pearls in this matthew it's such a
it's such a fun
uh interesting read and you're somebody
i've wanted to talk to for so long so i
i can't tell you how much i appreciate
this i'm really grateful well my
pleasure i'm looking forward to it um
the first thing would be just how
why why write a book you must be sick of
answering that but but uh no it's a
great question i mean i've been keeping
journals for 36 years
stuff that i found interesting to me
the original journals you know 14 years
old were like any 14 year old kid is
going to write something down why do i
have pimples why did gretchen break up
with me that kind of stuff the pimple
story is amazing i mean just that i mean
it sounds like that that
that's one of many that i want to touch
on i it's going to be challenging to
talk about because i don't want to give
too much away i don't want to make you
just regurgitate a bunch of [ __ ] that's
already in the book and it's much better
in the book um but uh
yeah the pimple story there's your whole
journey is
some of the things that you hear about i
mean you've been in pop culture for so
long like the bongo thing and or or some
of the movies you've made i knew of this
stuff but um hearing it from your
perspective is so
entertaining and interesting oh thank
you well that's i was hoping so yeah so
i the to finish answering your first
question um
i
wrote for 36 years
and
so 15 years ago started threatening
challenging myself daring myself saying
hey you're going to go over that
treasure chest of diaries journals and
see if something's worth sharing and i
said nah nah nah i'll i'll die my wife
maybe if something's worth sharing
she'll do it so which was all a cop out
and then um
i don't know i had a ghostwriter when i
got the courage to go write a book i had
a ghostwriter first he worked for the
new york times we met one time he got
pulled off the project and as soon as he
got pulled off the project it was like i
realized that that was a gift you got to
go away and go write it yourself and so
with the little kick in the backside
from camilla my wife i headed out
and she said don't come back to you got
something and this is what i came back
with how long did it take you to compile
all that i know you'd been i loved the
idea of of uh because i'm getting a
camper van myself soon and the idea of
record i love recording notes to myself
in little stores how did you do that
what was that contraption like in the
van you say you recorded a lot on the
road
well i had a really top-end mic like
this but i had it on
i had at that time it was
cassettes is the the means of recording
okay so i had a cassette like walkman uh
clamped into the ceiling here as i'm
driving behind the driver's seat right
so i've got a cassette clamped in and
off of that i had one of those
metal bendable arms
you know hooked up really high in mic so
i would be driving down the road pull it
down reach up press record grab the mic
and pull it right here in front of me
and just drive it and and just dj into
it you're like you're like mad max
kerouac style yeah it's what it was yeah
exactly what it was that's all how long
did it take you to compile everything
and put it all together then i mean 10
years ago i went away for a few weeks
and
sort of
went through typed messages um
beer coasters pictures of things that i
would take of my arm because i'd be out
and write something down on my arm and
instead record i just take a picture of
it
and sort of move that from paper to
files and word documents
and then this trip was about going away
okay let's go through the word documents
find our greatest hits find if we can
see some sort of synthesis of
storytelling if they're if it finds some
themes
um and it was 52 total days solitary but
split up in five different trips i could
be 10 to 12 day trip solo i'd go off
have a 12 days with my self-writing
session come back home catch up on
honeydews handle things around the house
then jet out again and then it was a
year and a half of editing and mixing
matching as you see in the book it was
like
yeah where did we uh there's pictures
there's aphorisms there's there's uh
prescribes there's poems prayer so where
does it look cut and paste those yeah
through the book you know to either
call back let the reader
call back to the story you just finished
and let you know kind of here's how i
looked at it yeah or to project you
forward i thought i looked at like
making a a film the narrative story was
the main story
the prescribed poems everything like
that in between are the flash forwards
or flashbacks right little like uh stops
little little stop gaps um yeah yeah you
ha were there were there holes in your
memory your mount your recall is
incredible i mean some of the
uh the one the first one i want to talk
about is the australia story which um a
bunch of friends who have read the book
keep bringing up they're like god that
the dooleys uh are people i really want
to hear more about it's amazing and so
that's i think you want to meet him you
just don't want to stay with him right
for six months yeah
yeah it was a gift i mean it ended up
being there was this this obvious red
light in your life that ended up being a
long-term green light uh i want to know
a little bit more about them just
because that was such a funny part of
the story did have you stayed in touch
with them at all over the years have you
heard they've stayed in touch with me
meaning
yeah
meaning
um
i haven't talked to him in a couple
years but
since 1993
if i ever did
satellite press to australia
matthew we've got a great you're the
father here in the uh in the studio do
you remember this guy boom no oh no he'd
go there he'd go to the oh yeah he'd go
there
yes or if he didn't go there they'd go
we've got some pictures here
uh and they'd pull them up and or they'd
say hey we got someone online someone
just called in oh no be the dooley's and
i just
i i mean i
so yeah i've talked to many
many times
and obviously they never brought up how
weird it got i mean i'm sure that never
came up
no yeah no and i've chose not to
you know
well they don't know i'm always like hey
hey how are you good to see you
give her a kiss
it never came up they didn't bring it up
but i did i didn't i didn't rub it in
well
see now what about because there's a lot
of personal stuff i don't know why i
have to keep holding it up it's we're
not recording this and uh you've already
seen the book um
i there's so much personal stuff in
there how do you feel about
i mean
the dooley's not i'm sure is not if the
stakes aren't as high but somebody like
your mom reading the stuff in that and
some you know family members reading
that stuff have you gotten any
matthew what the [ __ ]
no i mean look these stories my family
we all know these and we we tell them
and and we we laugh really hard at our
warts
yeah i mean i'm not really honest
we do we're you know my mom i tell
stories that in this thing about violent
fights with my mom and dad about how
me and my brothers were punished that
some people go that's abusive and i'm
like no no no it wasn't that isn't how i
how i saw it or how it was received now
i went to my mom and she said
you know before i put the book out i
said look i told these stories true and
she true
and i'm going to share them and she read
them she was like oh absolutely all
that's absolutely true and then some she
goes i know you wish
she did say i do wish you would have
included more stories
of how it was almost all the time is
when me and your father were getting
along yeah and i go and it made me think
because i was like so why do i tell
these
sometimes violent stories
that are the stories i want to tell to
show you how much we loved each other ah
yeah i believe the answer is
because that's the time where the love
that we have was tested the most
right never failed
right when the stakes were really high
it wasn't kumbaya i mean knives were
drawn blood was drawn oh [ __ ] this is
where it's gonna blow up this is where
this is where the story in their life
turns into a horror story which it never
did
but it's also matthew probably the stuff
that really stuck with you i mean that's
that's the stuff that uh that forms you
i guess
yeah i mean i
you know i've been asked a lot how did
what do you mean at four years old when
you're seeing your mom and dad fighting
she's pulled a knife on him how did that
not
i don't know yeah brand you in a poor in
a bad way or in an unhealthy way
and i don't know the answer except
you know that story ends up with them
making love on the kitchen room floor
right so it might have been different
again the love was always going to win
you know i don't i don't i i i never we
had a thing in our household you know i
i love you i just don't like you right
now well i tell a lot of the stories
when we didn't like each other but
the love was never in question so i
don't know why even at that young age
that was never in question for me well
there's also something so prime what i
found interesting about that because i
had such a different childhood to say
that's such an understatement uh
but but the
the love
was uh palpable there was something very
uh obvious about that but also there was
something primal about the way those the
way those lessons were uh taught to you
especially with your dad you know that
yeah
which
it it's if there's fat it's fascinating
there's something animalistic about it
and that's very beautiful and and that's
where my you know that's also where my
dad came from that's how that's how he
learned those rights of passion it
almost goes back
it's very uh tribal it's very african
totally it's like you know it's it's
it's um
a young man's right to passage you're
going to have to go out and prove and
you're going to it's going to have to
can you face the monster
and look them in the eye yeah you know
can you drink can you bring the kill
home so to speak i mean right so it
wasn't literally that but it was close
look i'll say this so for instance when
i told my dad
i tell the story about the bar and brawl
where i took out the bouncer which was a
big rite of passage for me and my
father's eyes ah
my son
risked the consequences
right of of getting in a fight with
somebody who was bigger than him that
had put their hands on me
ah there's something in my father that
was like he didn't say this but i'm sure
it's true
okay now he's more prepared to go out
into the world and say i'm gonna i'm i'm
gonna risk myself whether yeah and for
him it's always a physical thing he was
a physical guy he was a football player
he grew up that's how he was disciplined
in his own rights of passage but i'll
also say this when i called my dad in
the story in the book where i say i
don't want to go to law school anymore i
want to go to film school
that was a huge rite of passage
because what he heard in my in his son's
mouth over the phone which was me going
down this is what i want to do he goes
you sure i said yes sir
as quick as i said yes sir and the way i
said it and when i told him i don't want
to go to law school i want to go to film
school he heard my voice that i was not
asking him permission
he heard in my voice that i was actually
saying this is what i'm doing and
actually she was like don't have that
yeah you had proven those convictions on
on a field on a primal field but you had
proven them
uh yeah but if i would have like
stuttered if i'd have been like
i think i want to uh he pushed me right
back and said no way like don't you come
a bluffing you know what i mean right
it's like the pizza story i mean it's
like when you confused you and you
weren't he just wanted to hear you say i
i did this i own it uh
and that's all he wanted to hear
and i couldn't do it yeah i wimped out
man well that's the other thing your
honesty and it is so refreshing and it
leads to real um discovery i mean it's
it's
something else about the book that
really struck me it's it's very even
about like hair loss i was like that's a
you know for a hollywood actor to like
i don't know talk about that stuff i
find it very admirable um
so you mentioned that that decision uh
going to film school rather than law
school did i was did you have specific
desire to be an actor then or did you
just want to tell the way you talk about
in the book is that you just want to
tell stories and you're a hell of a
storyteller uh but did you do school
plays or anything was there any kind of
acting before that i didn't um
i mean i think i was in a church play
one time uh-huh but i did i did um
yeah so yeah i played joseph and
yeah okay yeah so i did that one i did
that one sunday um when i was eight or
whatever no but i didn't i didn't ever
uh uh
pursue it i didn't take acting classes
now when i look back
me going to film school
and wanting to tell stories i think
i did want to be in the front of the
camera but one
was not able to
admit it
meaning
i looking back on the diaries i it was
just
to say i want to go in storytelling to
say i want to go to film production
film production sounded more legitimate
like a legitimate company move get good
at a craft work but these you say i want
to go be an actor and i'm going to go
out solely and i just want to be my own
bill of goods and perform
to like what that's like a hobby that's
a saturday idea that's not you don't
make a living doing that so that's as
far as i could go
even in my own mind and i say this in
the book i never
being an actor was never even i couldn't
even allow it to be in the vernacular of
my dreams i never even dreamed about it
if that would have come into my dream
i'd have woke up oh okay that's not real
you can't do that you know so
but then if i look back in film school i
did though when you make films and you
get groups of four you get a dp an aed a
director sure and a performer
i did find that in those act in film
school the other classmates would say
hey will you matthew come be our actor
uh-huh so i was and i was and i was
always happy that they would ask me to
do it and then when i would be directing
i would jump over from the camera and go
like this
so i was doing it naturally yeah you
know well so did you ever do do you now
harbor
any desire to be a director to do the
behind the scenes stuff there's two
stories one of them is that dooley story
and another one is a magic reality
children's film that i wrote that i
think i would be the person to direct it
but the closest
i've gotten
to that which was which i loved and
wanted to do more of was the writing of
the book
yeah yeah you know we go we go
act we're doing somebody else's script
directed by somebody else
lensed in the camera by someone else
edited by someone else there's four
filters from our raw expression and very
worthy filters but
i wanted to go wait i want to go write
my own script i want to direct it i want
to edit it i want to see it through my
eyes and that's what the writing was now
there's still one filter because it's a
written word
you know stand up is no filters right
you know live performance just no
filters but
i don't know i there's a couple stories
that i if i feel like i have to
that those two stories that i've written
are two stories that i would feel like i
would be the best to be behind the
camera on game four well the dooley's
another thing that stands out about that
story was i don't think i've ever heard
you you're somebody who is so often
um imitated i mean so many people
myself included do impressions of you
and you mention that in the book you
refer that you have a you know i i'm
curious what you think of that and like
and and when people do that what do they
often screw up like are there things
that
you hear in those impressions that you
think i don't do that or like has it
pointed out certain things that you're
now self-conscious over aware of
no it really hasn't i mean look i i like
a good one i think i say that in the
book i like a good impression of me
um
you look the fun if someone's
it doesn't it doesn't sounds good i
don't think it works as much if
someone's pitch doesn't get low enough
that's right that's right and that's
right it's down there now somebody you
know can also start to exaggerate the
legato of like every single word is me
kind of riding which is an exaggeration
but it's it's not quite well that sounds
like the way you do your brother in the
book because i heard the book too i was
listening to it
and it was which is the way to do it for
anyone who's listening now it's a great
book but i would say a whole other
experience is just hearing the
performance of the book and the dooley's
thing reminded me of that because your
impressions of all these people of
course i don't know the dooleys but i've
heard joel schumacher i've heard richard
link letter you're doing incredible
impressions of these people um and i
just assume then that your br that
rooster sounds like that and pat's not
these people in your life that i've
never heard sound like that
um
have you always had a gift for that did
that just come from storytelling where's
that from i i think it came from just
storytelling i've always looked i love
music and so i think what people
like about imitating my voice and the
way i talk is the certain musicality of
it
um yeah it's almost like uh you know
look i i've i can go somewhere and i can
be recognized but if i open my mouth oh
yeah people go
i know who you are
i think it's a certain almost musicality
something but i love hearing the music
just as you know with anybody you're
here if you find the music the meteorite
music right and how they talk
then
then i click in so yeah i mean you know
i've got some very expressive brothers
and and and and and and family and i've
seen some very expressive characters
through my life that there the music of
their voice at that time branded itself
on me and i was like oh [ __ ] yes yeah
okay i've never heard that before
uh-huh are there people in your um
people that might be you have
recognizable voices like do you do i
guess i'm trying to ask do you do
impressions of other known people i i
really don't i never you know and if you
asked me to do an impressions right now
i'd get i'd get really self-conscious
and and and anxious okay my next
question is gone
um
i bet you do cole i bet you do
kohlhauser
see on the point to do cole kenny cole
kenny
matthew
they offered me fifteen thousand per
episode
okay they offered me fifteen thousand
president i called the boss i said i
like twos do you understand me
22 222 is what i should get paid
they come back to him with a 25 000
offer
he doesn't turn it what he says he turns
it down he goes you were not listening
you were not listening to me were you i
said i like twos
[Laughter]
i love him uh
i love him oh i also want to clear up
something about cole the bongo story
which i'll let people read about because
it's great the way you taught you write
about it
i had heard maybe from cole that he was
there was he there the night of the
series yeah
he was past he was like passed out in
the other room
oh that's funny so he just missed it he
missed out on all the wait did he wake
up and you were already gone arrested
no i if i remember correctly
mind you it was a bit hazy if i remember
correctly um
he came out after
i had already resisted arrest quite a
bit and there was enough noise going on
in my living room to wake a man up in
the other room okay what the hell is
going on out there okay okay all right
[Music]
i can't believe that that your first
scene in daisy confused and i know
you've talked about this a lot before
was that when you when you're driving up
to um
and you have the all right all right
line and again i don't want to ruin the
book but um
how difficult where you you talk about
your nerves in that and and when i
started out as an actor i i would play
kind of more tightly wound neurotic
characters so i could use the nerd the
nerves were helpful but but in that
scene you are so
cool you have a great quote about cool
um
you say cool never tries cool just is
how were you able to be
just how were you just there in that
scene do you
how did you do that
well let me say this all right the fact
that i had gone to film school did help
me
because i'd gone to film school
i understood
that that was the sound guy putting a
lavalier mic on me i understood that
that was a grip lighting the scene i
understood that there were other actors
i understood that that was the dp so by
knowing just what all these 80 people
doing
are standing around staring at you which
if i didn't know what they'd done in
film school i'm going you're going like
why is everyone staring at me is this
all about me well going to film school i
just said no everyone's got a job to do
and i'm a piece of it that was one so
that took away some intimidation of like
going why are the lights on me
is everyone is everyone relying on
whatever i do next you know what i mean
yeah
yeah yeah it did demystify a little bit
in a good way
um
and then
again i mean i had i understood the
music of the guy i remember i said when
rick said do you want to go
what about when you go try to pick up
the redhead intellectual marissa rabisi
who's the character of cynthia i said
sure wooderson likes all type of chicks
but then he goes you want to shoot it
and i go give me 30 minutes and i went
for a walk on my own and said who's my
man what am i about
so because my mind was going oh [ __ ]
what am i going to do there's no scene
here it's my first scene and acting what
am i going to do and as soon as i
leveled it down to like going here's the
four things you're about
that made me go
and i still do it with characters hey
you base each scene what are the what am
i about what i really want then
all the other stuff if it didn't have to
do with my car
rock and roll getting high or picking up
you know the redheaded intellectual it
was like it's not even getting my
attention man
not in my world you know what i mean so
i'm going
i remember in the moment going feeling
very secure with going well i'm in my
car
i'm listening to rock and roll
slater's gotta do be rolled up i'm
already that's prime time three out of
four and i'm going to get the fourth
thing that my character's about so good
so the rest of the world just kind of
went away
so good because i was like oh i'm in
this my character's in the salad days
and you talk about having seen your
brother as like an eleven-year-old and
and that was the image that stuck with
you for wooderson um and that epitome of
cool just like
kicking back
uh i a very specific question about that
the way you say cool
the way you say the word cool was that
your brother too
cool cool that's probably heading out
yeah she goes all right maybe we'll see
you later
yeah well that's just
you know
i mean my brother was that he had that
low eyelid
you know lazy hand kind of
never intruding your space you know kind
of always shoulders back leaning back
here man not too ambitious about
anything that's not
presently in my periphery
okay so there's this self-contentment
right you know what i mean and that's in
and not trying to play in an attitude of
cool like i said right cool just is the
coolest people
i know extremely cool nerds yeah because
they're like they know they're nerds
like totally
you know what i mean
it's the dorks i don't like because the
door is going to be whatever you think
whatever they think you want them to be
at every situation
and by the flip side i know cool people
quote unquote who are there's something
really lame about the way they try too
hard
you know yeah yes i i i know i know them
too and i've probably been
been them from time to time
i've definitely been them
uh you're you're also during days
confused your your dad died i didn't
realize he died in the middle of the
filming um yeah how how how did you do
that how did you focus on work after
that especially your first thing were
there
were there people in the cast that you
leaned on was it um did you just
compartmentalize
how the hell did you do that
well
a little bit of all i mean rick
i leaned on a little bit
rick i shared rick and i had already
kind of formed a little bit of
relationship but we would
you know we're talking our conversations
led to talking about
life and philosophizing what's what it's
about we were doing that before my
father passed so
five days into shooting and now i'm
being invited back i'm in and i'm in
that first night
led to the second night led to the third
i'm getting invited back to the set
every night this is so much fun i'm
getting 320 a day every time i leave at
night people are going great man see you
tomorrow you're really good at this i'm
like going [ __ ] great cool can i come
back yeah please come back tomorrow
night so i was having a great time i
felt like
i was enjoying what i was doing so much
that i felt like is this avian question
is this even legal can you can i have
this good of a time
and get paid 320
a day
and
well
i'd love to get along get away with this
as long as i can yeah i've had that dad
dies you know it's a great feeling the
past the girls the everything around
yeah
i go home
we do my father's death we have our late
nights in the kitchen which is where i
always hear and talk about death
consistently through my family for some
reason i don't know why it's the kitchen
but and then we have the wake
and
then i go back and something in me i
think part of it was
i felt like i was on the precipice like
i had just begun something
that i may just actually
love for the rest of my life
it was bad i never had anything before
that
and i think also
inadvertently
i had a bit of
almost charm
to the fact that dad was alive for that
he didn't come to set but he was alive
for the fir for me he oh his life
overlapped
what his son me matthew
that's now been doing for five days his
life overlapped me starting the first
thing that i would do in my life that
may not be a fad
his life had overlapped the first thing
his son matthew done that was going to
be more than a hobby maybe
right you know what i mean so
i very quickly sort of felt a little
serendipity in that yeah and then i went
back and
i guess if it was definitely grounded me
and the same way i was saying earlier
going to film school knowing what
everyone does demystified well my dad
died now i'm really
less impressed right the idea of oh i'm
in front of a camera in this great wow i
could be i could be an actor ooh hey one
day maybe i'm famous and all that was
like i was much less impressed with that
you get out of here dealing with life
and death yeah i was i just i'd been
baselined by the death of my father
you know so then
i would say my heels got further into
the ground and then i just
was able to i guess channel that sort of
groundedness i had into going
well that's this living water wooderson
was pretty fun shoes to to to sit in
during that time i mean i don't know
what i would have done with other with
it with other characters if that would
have happened if that would have been my
first time
um but maybe back to your question about
compartmentalizing i mean i
there was no question my family like
made me go back to get back to set go
back it's what dad would want you to do
so i also had that i truly believe that
that's what my dad wanted me to do go
back and finish the job you started also
go back and finish the job that you
started the first job you've actually
loved that you might
we don't know remember this is back in
90 days that you might be able to do
again or learn to love in your life so i
had a
commitment coming out of my dad
moving on too
it's the same guy who stayed with the
dooleys for uh yeah lo those many months
yeah uh it's really admirable it shows a
real strength and um what do you what do
you think your dad would think about
what what then happened to you as a
result of that decision to go back
well i think he would i think he would
have loved it what i miss
you know he was uh i come from a family
of hams and i'm probably out of five of
us my two brothers myself my mom and dad
i'm probably fourth i'm probably number
four
it goes mom
dad rooster me then pat
and i'm yeah i go between number four
and five of the biggest hams in my
family so dad would have
dad would have loved it i talk about how
mom loved it in sort of an uncomfortable
way she loved my fame in a way that she
wanted my fame so in wanting my fame i
lost my mother
my dad
would have still been a dad he would
have loved it and i see guys say this in
the book he would have been on the front
row
but he wouldn't have had to be on stage
right that's interesting how did you
mend that matthew because that's got to
be i mean i
i very few people can relate to that i
think but navigating that post fame
relationship with her how did you
finally mend things with her
well is that for another podcast
no no no it's good because i mean it was
an endurance test yeah look i i knew i
loved my mom that was unconditional it
wasn't like when i say we were estranged
if she got sick or something it wasn't
like i would go well i'm not going home
no that would have trumped
our relationship that was what was hard
about our relationship at that time with
her
uh
liking and wanting the fame that i had
so much
it went on for about eight years
the hard part was
my calls on sunday which was a ritual
called mom on sunday were just very
short and scientific they were they were
not emotional i didn't share we didn't
grow i didn't share with her i was
feeling about things because i feared
hell i might read about it people
magazine monday right you didn't you
didn't trust her no i hadn't i didn't
trust him she gave me great reason not
to yeah yeah yeah yeah um and that's
what you need at that point when things
are changing like that and you're i mean
that's a strange well you know you get
fame over over a weekend you do it's an
imbalancing act so you try to find your
balance and so
what i was looking for is some people in
my life that were stable
that that i could go to to help me
navigate but it was a time when i went
to my mom and
well she was rocking the boat even more
so i was like whoa so my my calls to her
were very sort of clinical i would just
you know wouldn't you know but they i
would still make the calls so after
about eight years here's what happened
is
and after my older brother's telling me
man matthew
we applaud you you're you you
are showing extreme endurance in trying
to change mom and we're just here to
tell you
it ain't gonna happen but damn you're
making a valiant try so after about
eight years now my career gets a little
more stable i'm a little more stable
with fame i understand what matters what
doesn't i'm sort of i'm in now right i'm
not auditioning i'm i'm sort of in right
now i'm like all right you know what i'm
my ship's stable enough that i'm gonna
take the reins off of mom
and invite her to the red carpets and
tell her you damn right you can go talk
to whoever you want you tell a story to
whoever you want because i felt like i
now my ship was stable enough that she
couldn't sink me
and so when i when i took the reins off
oh she wasn't shy about jumping right
back in and telling every story out of
the sheep
she's coming out here next actually
she's i mean she's she's awesome at it
and so and what happened then
is that now
i felt stable enough that these stories
mom were telling 99.9 of them were
awesome stories i was like
that's laughing great yeah you can tell
that now you couldn't tell that i didn't
want you to tell that story though eight
years ago mom you know i didn't need any
more frequency any more noise i didn't
need another headline i didn't need
somebody asking well wait what about
what's your mom say i'm just trying to
deal with what i can deal with in my own
situation right now right so eight years
have gone by i stabilized enough to take
the reins off over and let her go and
she's she's been great
that's that's interesting it's also like
you know she didn't see how fickle fame
was i mean you got to see firsthand
in a way that
so few people see
how fickle that that whole
thing is and
i guess to anyone else it's like
you know it's it's just cool it's just
like wow you get to go to the premieres
and you get to do all that [ __ ] and the
trappings are still exciting
uh to a lot of yeah well to most people
yeah sure i mean look
you know
too many options can make a tyrant out
of any evidence
and when you get access you get
affluence you get fame in the word too
many yeses
yeah in a world of becomes ruthless
yeses
oh man
let's send that person some uh some some
some some guidance because
boy you can go and that that's that's
the challenge is that you have so many
you can
you succeed in hollywood you're having
so many options of yes so many of course
you can be whatever you want hollywood
come out be whoever you want to be well
if you can be whoever you want to be and
do anything and everyone's going yes
have another do this more uh-huh [ __ ]
you can look up
some of us some some people look up and
they're done some people look up and go
whoa what am i surrounded with i'm not
even myself anymore
um it's a challenging thing especially
when you never had the option to have
those things before
right right and you're just damn
grateful to be there and so you want to
say well i've never even what do you
mean am i going to say yes or no
i'm going to say yes because i never
even had the option yesterday of course
yeah and you talk about the great
lengths that you went to to navigate
those weird waters in south america
africa these incredible trips and
stories that i won't um i'll let people
read for themselves but um who who are
the people
that that you rely on to say no to you
now um who are the people in your life
um
to say no
well
my wife camilla and i
she can say
no and
does she go
but she challenges me in the right way
to hear
you know if i want to do something i i
pitch her
and if she ends up going like yeah okay
yeah
that means that either that's the
leading towards no or i better get a
better pitch
because she wants to hear she wants to
hear a convicted pitch where she sees me
like again
here it's non-negotiable for me and
here's why then she's like ah
now i got it yes so if i don't get to
that place
if she gets a no or she doesn't get to
give me a yes on something it either
means i didn't pitch it well enough or
it's probably not
gonna fly
at all um
and
i mean i have counts i have people
that i
talk to about general
general vision and i try to have people
that i work with that can help me
realize that vision they'll put the
pieces
in place for me to achieve it um
it's not
a democracy
i mean
you know i mean i mean but i but i i
hope and i do i think that most of the
time i have my ears in the right place
for people
that are giving me the right resistance
for the right reasons
and i can hear that and go yeah yeah
that's not passing the test and i do
when i get when i'm really convicted on
something i then go okay now i'm so sure
that this is the right move to make now
i'll gather up and i do have friends
including my wife to go now let's
punch holes all over the sink let's
illegitimize this as an idea all the way
down
um and and just and just power play it
and try and just bring it to the ground
and see if it can stand up yeah if the
idea can stand up what is the next big
idea do you have something in the works
next big idea for me right now is
who am i going to be in this big show
called life
this one where action was called one
time we were born in cuddle be called
one time when we when we die what am i
going to do how is there a useful
leadership role that i can step into
i've really enjoyed seeing how green
lights has been
translated and people have gone you know
what
i got this from it um i'm in i'm for how
do i think we we
we build a better world to live in build
better people to live in it
um and you know that parlayed with
the non-negotiable roles that i have as
a father and a family and a husband
i'm looking at you
what's this character i'm gonna play
live
you know uh matt
matthew are there things as a father
that you do that you think
oh [ __ ] these are this is remnants of my
dad that like maybe i don't want to
adopt maybe i want to
i don't want to put into practice um
right or and conversely are there things
that
you lean on i mean that he taught you
sure in terms of father sure
um
more the second
look i
my parents my dad was big on instilling
the values and there were four in
particular
uh don't lie don't say you can't
um
uh
don't hate that was from mom and then
mom's other one was don't answer
to anything other than your name which
is ironic because we give nicknames our
family gives nicknames to everybody
do you have a nickname because she
insists i never had a nickname stick
and i i'm a good i'm a good nickname
giver i'm a good nickname giver and and
i've given thousands of them and they've
stuck and people have
given me some my nickname would be
mcconaughey people going mcconaughey
saying my last name and not saying
matthew um
but so
i i'm very much still want to instill
those
values of my children but i do go about
it differently than my my mom and dad
did
my mom and dad it was again it was it
was consequences we're physical corporal
and
we ain't talking about the why the why
is because i said so
that was it you know so what are they
doing when you're explaining more things
now i see i see i was going to say well
when your kids say why
you explain
as much as we can and any parent out
there knows
you can't
do it forever because
you'll never sleep
right you'll go through the night
through school you'll miss school you'll
miss work it can go on and on and on and
on so there has to come a time where
hopefully explain it right where they
understand it and sometimes we're
successful with that and sometimes we're
less successful
but we talked things out a lot more than
my parents did
with me but still want to instill the
same values that my parents yeah
well it worked they did something right
i mean no i think they did i don't you
know i have no i don't
poorly judge how they did it either i
don't feel it's my place to
you know whether you go
whether someone believes in a
you know a bow open or not i don't
remember
any of the
immediate
pain from the boat but what i remember
is like when i lied to my dad
i remember the the pain on his face and
feeling like he hadn't done
he hadn't bothered me the right way that
he could get across that i didn't need
to do that
that hurts you know
that was what that's what i remember
yeah um
[Music]
and again i want to pray you know
and and i want to preface to say this we
were never
injured
it was just like let's they were a get
it over with i remember it was like a
we're not going to we're not going to
ground you because grounding takes away
your time and your time is your most
valuable asset so turn around here take
take three licks and it's over with and
it was like
i love that logic yeah i remember
getting hit and it always struck me that
even at the time even as a kid i could
tell that it hurt my parents
to do it you know and that was the shame
of like i made them do this or like soap
in the mouth or all that um right well
the hard part is
it's easier when we know
if we're except for the consequences of
of our wrongdoing and we know that we
did wrong
what's not easy is if you get punished
you're like i still don't know what i
did wrong i don't get it i don't know
what i did wrong you know what i mean
i'm not growing yeah yeah right but boy
when you know yeah cause i look back and
i go man i earned every one of them yep
sure did really and then got a few with
quite a few more that i never got caught
for you know what i mean so
life could be a dream
this pandemic has obviously changed
everyone's mental health and people are
struggling with that people are juggling
child care working full-time in their
homes
you know there are a lot of new
challenges that that are uh we're
dealing with it's a lot to handle and so
that's where talk space comes in
talkspace is a space it's a virtual
space for um people who are maybe
struggling with mental health who want
to talk to a therapist i think anyone
should talk to her even if you think i'm
okay i'm i think therapy is just you
know whatever we've talked about it
before it is invaluable talkspace has
thousands of licensed therapists they're
trained in over 40 specialties including
anxiety depression relationships and
more your therapist can help you set and
achieve your goals i know from
experience what therapy can do how much
it's meant to me in my life and how much
i feel like i've grown from it try talk
space it's a great way to start therapy
if you've never done it before because
it's um inexpensive and you can talk to
somebody 24 7. and as a listener of this
podcast you'll get a hundred dollars off
your first month with talkspace to match
with a licensed therapist today go to
talkspace.com
or download the app make sure to use the
code long to get a hundred dollars off
your first month and show your support
for the show
[Music]
another question i had uh the tree house
yeah so you built that tree house all
summer it's a great story you go and you
steal the equipment i thought that was
gonna end with um
your dad making you tear it down or
something but you just moved
um like he knew the whole time that he'd
been stealing it and he was like listen
boy this is the lesson i'm going to
teach you but so you just had to move
and it and no we moved he never knew
about the treehouse i got away with it
completely wow he never knew that i was
sneaking out at night to steal lumber to
build that tree house he no one ever saw
that tree house besides me and my brown
lunch brown paper bag at lunch
oh my god you're like huck finn
uh
you and and that with that oil company
what was it called my mom knew we were
listening i was listening to it with my
mom uh uh we were driving upstate to see
family and she was like i remember that
it was kind of like a oil of melt
door-to-door oil mink yeah yeah yeah
it's a great story and i i hope people
aren't sick of me saying it's a great
story i'll let you read about it but um
did you are they around still is that
still a compliment oh i'm pretty sure
they're out of business i'm not sure if
they would have come out there baby
right
well
or run from us you know still going hey
i don't know
um i don't think they're still in
business if they are hey you're out
there listening
there's a great story about you and uh
and in my book cream
it's a great story um
austin is something another um
point of connection that i just love
it's a town i've loved ever since the
first day i went there um for a job it
was the first time i went and uh
god do i love it i but you talk about it
in the late 90s and how it was like a
safe place for you and um
how is it now what's your relationship
with it like now because i i just know
how much it's changed um
yeah i had a place there but it's
changed so much that
i wonder how you feel about that well it
has um
and that's one of my uh uh what i think
the challenges right now is is
austin
a city that i love that's been good to
me and i hope i've been good to it
how do we as a city
maintain
our dna our village values our our
village values of nobody's too good and
everybody's good enough
in in a in a growing metropolis
yeah um how do we not
you know as we're the most popular kid
in school right now right and right tech
is is a huge migration of tech and
banking and lawyers and and institutions
that are moving there
how do
you know i want to remind new i want to
remind
newcomers hey don't try and turn here
into why you left there
how do we make sure we don't consume
more than we create
you know you moved here for a reason
sure
mainly a big tax break for texas but you
also austin's a place that's got its
identity and it's cool because of the
people it's a hospitality town we don't
have dignity
well that's the only that's really the
only rule
in getting along in austin or earliest
general that i've seen across the board
works all you gotta do is be you
yeah that does not mean keep austin
weird does not mean hey go do an
eccentric thing because hey it's weird
no no no no that it's just all you got
to do is be you
and it's a place where like
you know if you're
like i said i first pulled into town my
brother talked me into it he goes you're
gonna love it i go like for instance
what he goes you know how you like all
kinds of people man you'll pull up to a
bar you're gonna have the sheriff to the
left of you uh a lesbian to the right an
american indian on the other side of the
sheriff and a four-foot blue-haired
dwarf on the other side and everyone's
drinking together having a great time
maybe two lesbians to the right maybe
two maybe three you
know you know
but it's it's it's and it's that it's
that it's it's at its best
the dna of austin is if somebody
one of those people who may look like an
outcast got up on their proverbial soap
box and said hey
um
lesbian or i'm i'm i'm i'm dwarf and
you're yelling the best of austin
goes
oh
i didn't i don't care
right i mean like it never mattered
right to us
you know what i mean that's the that's
the best of uh of austin so we've got
we're you know we're gonna go through
we're going through growing pains right
now we're going through adolescence
and the weird the weirdness of it is
that it's not weird like nothing's weird
well and and then again
you know it's there's a there's a
there's a new there's a new banner in
austin and i'm all for the progress link
ladder and i talk about this are all for
the growth man there's a lot of assets
to it interesting people coming to town
just want to make sure we don't look up
in 15 years and look at ourselves in
austin and go who the hell do we become
or or
what are we
right you know what i mean even worse
and then people leave to go somewhere
else so it's a sustainable place and
it's got a sustainable ethos to it that
i believe is worth maintaining while we
embrace progress
well i look forward to running into
there one of these days um
uh are you excited about steve
sarkeesian's uh
hire
yeah i'm getting there you know um
i'm looking forward to hearing i'm
looking forward to talking to him i got
some things i want to talk to him about
a friend of mine a guy i knew was a
safety at ut he said you used to come is
this true you come into the locker room
and you give pep talks to the players
yeah
yeah or go to practice
you know i'll talk i'll go i'll i'll go
to the i'll go to the coach
um from mac brown to charlie strong to
herman and others and always check in
first
where's the team's head right now
you know you got to talk to a team
differently
if they're going into a national
championship than if they're just coming
off of 48 to 3 loss
right yeah i mean unfortunately
more that
confidence levels are different and you
don't you know you don't need a team
going in to go play a big 12
championship confident does not need a
rod ross piece they need the hey let's
really focus
on what we need to do speech so we're
not overly hyped um a team coming off a
48-3 loss
needs sometimes more of the raw rob but
hey you know you may have lost to battle
but are you ready to rebuild here how
are we going to do that so i enjoy
talking to them they're a bunch of
really good young men i've got i try to
stay in contact as much as i can with
them and the coaches and i'm excited
about um sark let's see i'm looking
forward to talking to him he's really
making some strong hires right now it
looks like
um looks like today i just read that uh
the georgia dc
is coming to texas oh no kidding yeah i
don't think it's not fine yet but it
looked like it looked like that he that
that uh he may be the defender
coordinator so let's see you come to
texas man
texas longhorn football you're getting
the hand of the keys to the ferrari
um yeah and we got to do it and i think
texas overall the university of texas
has to start looking at uh because we do
have so much spotlight on us we have to
start looking at like
it's us against the world i mean like we
need to even play like underdogs because
right we have so much spotlight on us
yeah yeah yeah um i'm excited for next
season uh you said something about
honeydews you said i gotta return home
i meant to ask you about it
what does that mean what do you mean by
that well it's a you know it's a
flippant term for
come back and
spend some time with the family
not like do it shortly i don't not the
literal sense of like do a chore list
like honey do this but i just use the
flippant word to mean like oh honey oh i
got you i thought you meant like the
melon no no no no no no
honey did it yeah it could be no but i
just mean i come back and do your
honeydews you know what i mean like i
got to do this guy just gotta i love it
gotta take care take care of things
around the house
stabilize back the relationships a
father and a husband yeah i'm going to
steal it i'm stealing it
okay this is this is a lightning round
man i could talk to you for hours but i
know that uh you got a heart out at five
so um if you would indulge me let's go i
got a lightning round yeah real quick uh
do you text a lot and if you do what's
your most commonly used uh emoji if you
use emojis
i don't use emojis
for email over text because
uh-huh
if you text me
all right and i'm an and
and i'm driving i get to the red light
and i check to see that you texted me
but then the light turns green
now that i've opened that text
i can't put the flag by it to say you
got to go back and remember it so all of
a sudden i get to my destination an hour
later i got six more texts yours is six
deep and i don't even have it flagged i
forget you texted me well why not just
not look at it when you're at the red
light well we all know how hard that is
to do
because we're talking because because
maybe i'm on my way to see you and it's
a piece it's a quick direction to go are
you on your way and i'm just going to
write yes before the light turns green
but it turns out to be a question and
i'm going like oh i really want to put
some thought into that before i answer
and i don't have time to answer that
this red light so i gotta go but i
wasn't able to mark it
counterpoint that's when emojis come in
handy you just go
or uh
i i yeah
god bless the emoji in some ways because
you know you can write
if you write me something and you're
you're you're you're in a laughing mood
and you're you're right you're about to
give me some [ __ ] right
uh and so you write me in a way that's
like i'm
jabbing you but i just woke up i'm in a
ticked off mood i respect the exact same
words but i'm like
what the [ __ ] is that man and without
unless you put the wink at the end
right but i do like i do like to write
well enough
to actually have the person think
i understand what i'm saying without the
emoji but i understand yeah i appreciate
the shortcut of the emoji
well and it helps like like you said in
the book i love this expression vince
vaughn says this a lot let me i'll set
the table for you it helps it helps to
set the table it does it does yeah it
does yeah
um if if you had to use an emoji just
for our thing just for
i like the wink man i like the wings but
i like but but but i i like the wink in
real life as well i'm actually happy
you're a winner got my wink and i love a
good little wink that means i'm dancing
through life
and i find that when i've lost my weak
or i'm not whistling as much
i usually need to go head out and when i
go to on solo trips to africa or south
america or places i got i get my wink
back
okay okay
um i like that uh if you could be a
professional athlete what sport would
you play and why
well
the one that i know
i have a mind for that i did get
down to a four handicap was golf
oh yeah i'm no longer i'm probably 25
handicapped now but i got good enough
from 18 from from 16 to 23 where
i had some game and that was the one
that i was like oh it's such a mental
game that i love
um would you ever
would you ever bet on the bills again
bills are doing so well now uh you got a
great story
might do it tomorrow baby
uh um
not a bad bet tomorrow no i hear you um
yeah because now if i got off the train
right
they're gonna i mean it's time to say
like four's a charm you know
right they're looking good they're on
the move but they said that against the
oilers yes they did
i remember that game i i it's so funny
to relive that game because i was a kid
when that was going on and i thought the
stakes were high for me i was like
really into it but to think that yet all
that money in vegas um it's a great
story one of many um if you could have
one snack food for the rest of your life
what would it be
oh dill pickles
[Laughter]
i wish i were wearing my shirt i just
had my grillo's pickle shirt what's your
brand what's your go-to well right now
i'm into i rotate but i'm into these uh
these these texas sweet heat uh dill
pickles that are
really nice i'm a fan of the smaller
dill gherkins just because i like it
really crispy yeah man and but cold
let's get them in let's get them cold
and then late night let's get out a few
of the different kind of nice italian
cheeses we have and a few different
mustards and let's sit back and have a
good time a couple picklebacks hit some
uh some whiskey and picklebacks um yes
do you get real snacky when you smoke
are you are you um
do you get munchie
weed used to be a muncher's deal yeah
cause i know you smoke with woody and
those guys i've smoked that stuff is
intense yeah no let me just all right
let me just tell you this i'll tell you
a time and i cuz you heard the snoop
story and this is a similar snoop story
uh-huh let me tell you about the time i
got on willy's bus oh for the first time
okay
they're over for a barbecue and i'm the
one i'm the one doing the grilling okay
so i've already got the steaks marinated
and everything
now we go get on his bus oh no
here we go well all i know is next thing
i know i'm starting to go through those
where the subplots are getting a little
unmanageable
and
i start all of a sudden i go oh oh [ __ ]
the stakes are burning
oh no i got it oh no and i run out of
the bus and i go to the grill i hadn't
even started the grill yet much less
taking the steaks out of the fridge
oh boy that's amazing you know yeah
fast forward too fast whoa whoa whoa
subplots uh andrew come on back over
yeah
uh what's
matthew what's your favorite movie of
movie sequel of all time
movie sequel of all time
well
[Music]
and while you're dwelling on that this
might help
jog your memory who's who's your first
celebrity crush
um
lisa bonay
okay i'd like to point out for people
listening because no one's seeing this
matthew was contemplatively uh stroking
his chin while he said that
like a professor but i was joking it
before this question trying to remember
what my favorite sequel was
it was great timing it was just really
good timing um we can get off the
sequels if you could get a tattoo if you
needed a tattoo what would you get and
where would you get it yeah 622. it's
what i have in my ring here
um my favorite verse in the bible if thy
i be single my whole body will be full
of light
it's about a third eye basically and
that's why i have it on my uh
ring wedding ring but i also have it as
you see facing me because it's not
really to remind you it's so i can look
at my hand and go hi
hi there it is
that's funny as you're doing this and
i'm listening to you uh i i'm reminded
of your your hand modeling days
uh which you talk about in the book you
do have really nice hands
they've made me about 160 bucks sir i
quit i quit biting my nails because
someone told me if you quit biting your
nails you might be able to make one of
your hands i quit that night
yeah i would that's a lot of money back
then it's commerce yeah yeah
yeah
uh what's your favorite fruit uh a nice
piece of ripe you're you just want to
tear into a yeah favorite fruit would be
baby man just i'm digging into a really
great asian apple right now
oh yeah
yeah hey uh darcy cardin that actress
friend of mine was just on the show same
thing a really great bite yeah juicy
well like our like we like our pickles
crispy clean clean
cold no no no skin's going to be hanging
it's a clean cut
yes yeah no nothing flapping going on uh
and
who would you want to play you in your
biopic in the story the matthew
mcconaughey's story oh my son oh
he's not his name an actor levi
levi but he'd have the best take on you
probably yeah well
in some ways
yeah our children are kind of going out
all everyone's children are versions
they're all going to play us of our
biographies you know what i mean right
um uh dogs are cats
that's a good one because we just picked
up some more dogs
and and
man they poop a lot
a cat a cat a cat
a cat so self-sufficient
yeah you know i'd say i'm a dog person
but man i do appreciate a good cat that
is like they can take you or leave you
they're going to be fine
right they they they
yeah
they do their thing uh do you have a
favorite simpsons character do you like
the simpsons i don't have a favorite i'm
scared i've never okay what about the
muppets were you a muppets guy growing
up no
no i wasn't allowed to watch much tv
growing up
no kidding
no we weren't we weren't allowed to uh
wow so you didn't have like a show that
you all watched or like
ah
wow and that was just a mandate from
your parents they just thought get out
there and play my that was mom's deal
she'd go turn that off quit watching
somebody do what you'd go out and do
yourself okay oh well again she
she did it right uh uh beetles are the
stones oh that's a great one
monkey man i've been obviously uh i've
been listening to a lot of both lately
actually yeah i've been listening to a
lot of both actually lately
um
matthew's beaming right now yeah well
this is this is this is a high-class
question
um
it matters what mood i'm in what what
drink i'm drinking that night because i
could just say you have a tequila you
got a cuervo a double cuervo you're at a
bar in um montana and you want to put go
to the jukebox if you want your stones
stones stones let's get the hip shape in
here let's get some syrup going yeah
okay i love it uh man i'm uh we're out
of time but i wish we had more and i
can't tell you what what a pleasure and
honor this was a true pleasure and i'm
really grateful to you for it well
thanks for inviting me i'm glad it came
on a good chat likewise man and uh and
we'll talk we'll we'll talk more
glowingly about the book when you're not
here so i appreciate it and uh
yeah thanks matthew happy friday still
the best day all right man all right
keep keep living thanks for the best do
the same all right i appreciate it
thanks brother
[Music]
so that happened and that's pretty good
so that happened
he's right when he talked about people
doing people do too impressions of him
he said too high that's i never realized
his voice was so deep yes deep and it's
and it's anything people over overdue
the legato well he that's you know sam
rockwell there's certain words you have
to really hang on it's he it sounds like
him do i said this to him it sounds like
him doing his brother in the book that's
how he reads his brother's voice it's
kind of like this but yeah certain words
and i've always noticed the one thing
that people don't really hit all the
time is that is the s's the way he
brings his mouth together for the s's
it's sort of like this this
matt damon does a really good one he
does yeah there's this he it's that's
the key is that and i've talked about
this with other guests there's always a
way into an impression it's usually like
one or just a few words
and that's why it's hard
chris and i were just laughing because i
i can't stop doing the all right after i
made this big pronouncement of retiring
it's iconic for a reason yeah it is
it's amazing that's his first thing
amazing first acting
really other than uh you know a music
video or something amazing he's ever
done i don't know if that's seen it he's
so natural and great in that movie i
know it may be too late for this but i
hate to labor this point i just don't
know if it's
if it's as um
mind-blowing
to
non-actors i don't want to alienate
people but if you have never
acted and
there's
it may be difficult to really grasp what
it what a feat that is to be that like
iconically laid back i mean he was so
laid back in that scene that it's like
when you think about laid back it's like
the uh the prototype it's just the
ultimate combination of he had this
natural ability yeah and he was
extremely
comfortable i thought that was
interesting that we talked and he knew
that i mean he would say oh i knew that
guy i knew the character i like how he
talks about that like i knew the guy i
knew my guy he was my guy and here's why
here's what he and he does it the way
you're supposed to do it he breaks down
this is what every actor should do what
do i want what does this guy want what
does he have what does he want how does
he plan on and then then you fill in
everything else after that after you and
he wants these basic things i love that
character and i love that movie but i
never
i after seeing that movie i was never
like oh he's gonna be the one from this
movie but i remember seeing was the next
year two years later or something a time
to kill
and i remember watching the movie and
thinking he's gonna be a huge star for
the rest of my life well it was one of
those performances where you're like oh
yeah he's like he's paul newman's like
our paul newman yeah see i not to and he
was i mean that's what happened a week
later
yeah i had i had also seen he had done
those smaller movies that he talks about
in his book
like texas chainsaw massacre the next
generation the new generation where he
plays this psychotic one
he's got this mechanical leg and he's
like this [ __ ] maniac in in um in
that movie and he's so good in that in
this like
b horror outra it's outrageous it's like
really over the top but he's so
committed he talks about in the book how
he
um
he he the audition he basically
auditioned with the casting director by
like you know really freaking around i
don't want to get into it but and i know
we said this a lot during this episode
but
i it's really worth listening to the
book i mean it is i wonder how
many of the things he talked about in
the pocket i was thinking that like do
people will people be a little lost will
they need to have heard the book first
uh i suspect they will be a little bit
you know because he you're talking about
the dualies a lot
with him and there's this family he
stayed within in australia and it you
know out of context it won't maybe we
should have set it up in the beginning
the dooley's thing that's okay i i think
it was clear that it was this family
this weird family in australia that he
lived with but it's definitely worth uh
listening
or reading the book because
um they're really funny stories and that
story he tells particularly well because
he
it's this kind of slow burn setup it's a
great payoff he may be our first guest
that we've had on the show
who doesn't know who you are
and i noticed that you kept trying to
sneak in a little bit like sneaky we
know mutual people he talked about vince
and cole house
yeah and he never really took the bait
he was never like oh you know call yeah
cool i know
how do you know cole right i think
you're right i i don't think he's ever
heard of you and here's what he may he
may have who knows he's so cool that it
doesn't give it away though no
and here's the thing if he i don't know
what's what's worse for me if he does
know me he just doesn't give a [ __ ] or
he doesn't know me and he doesn't give a
[ __ ]
what's worse uh but i see to say he
doesn't put the [ __ ] no no no like he
did the show he was of course he was
totally game to answer all the like
questions yeah no no that's not doesn't
give a [ __ ] just doesn't um
it wasn't important
yeah it should have been why should you
be i know i'm not saying i should be i'm
not bothered by it
it'd be nice if he did it would have
been nice if he had been like oh [ __ ]
like
i i've
vin speaks glowingly about you
but whatever you're right he did the
show that's not who he is though i can't
imagine him no he doesn't like butter up
to people no he's too cool yeah yeah
that's not cool to do he seemed to like
you yes yeah you got along you right
yeah he was laughing he seemed like he
had a good time yeah we had fun i had
fun talking to him he's a fun person to
talk to but like yeah i didn't like hope
to run into you in austin he was like
what's the next question i know
uh at the top of the interview you um
you got a little gushy about his book
and
and you hadn't let him answer your first
question he said um
thanks thanks yeah uh just to answer
your first question there
and he he there's a little point the
fact that he said your first question
like you're not even letting me answer
your first question
yet yeah don't do this but then uh yeah
you uh didn't do that again yeah
thankfully yeah well i it was a cue it
was a real clear it's hard to you just
heard him give this great performance
right now pretty compelling book i know
over the course of several hours i know
leading up to this felt like i've been
like hanging out with you exactly i felt
like he was that's the thing about those
audio books that's really great about
depending on the book i guess but felt
like he was in the car with us you know
just telling these stories just us and
mom and matthew
he had such a different childhood than
us oh
that is such an understatement makes
perfect sense that he yeah is a very
different person than us now yeah we
just grew up so differently so many of
those stories those childhood stories
were like
nope can't
remotely relate to that um
and and look i am grateful so grateful
to my parents uh but that's
it's interesting about parenting and
raising kids that you can do it so
radically different yeah i'm not saying
one's better or one's worse it's just
completely different i'm a little
envious of his i have to say some parts
of it like yeah but but but i but also i
wouldn't want to trade no i know i know
but his father was uh very very
different and tough yeah tough and but i
also liked that he didn't he didn't know
simpsons he didn't know the muppets it's
because he wasn't really allowed to
watch tv and yeah i think that
is a really
good thing to do i mean and our parents
didn't let us watch a lot of tv either
so that was a similar thing we had but
um
it really fosters
imagination
adventure activity well he talks about
one so many kids just i know like watch
too much tv and play video games we
should contextualize a little bit like
for example one summer he he tells the
story about and we reference it in the
podcast going stealing lumber from a
nearby lumber yard he cuts a hole i mean
he goes through the whole thing he's
like he was like mischievous uh huck
finn or is that an oxymoron it was
redundant rather redundant redundant
um you said you told him you're like
huck finn yeah and then just silence and
um
but he goes and he builds this treehouse
he spent all summer building it every
day for hours and
uh and then they moved right away before
we got to enjoy it but i thought about
that and then later he tells stories
about going to africa and getting these
wrestling matches with uh the the towns
the local the villages like best
wrestler of in the
country uh in morocco so it i think what
it does is like to your point really
fostered a sense of i gotta get out
there and do i gotta tour he said he
lived out of a van i remember they
talked about this in the book this van
that he had this uh camper that he lived
in
and he and his dog would just travel
around the country adam shankman
uh because parts of the book you're like
is that true that can't be true it's
it's almost hard to believe but um
and that being one of them but i
remember adam shankman the director
telling me who directed the wedding
planner
he told me a crazy story
about
matthew having to meet him and he's like
i had to adam is such a different person
than mcconaughey i had he's like i had
to fly into albuquerque or whatever from
la you know he's this la guy
and he's like i need to drive to some
dusty diner out in the middle of the
desert
and mcconaughey showed up he strolled in
he was all like dusty and dirty and and
you know gorgeous of course and he sits
down and he's like to talk about the
script and his one note he was like i
think the character's name let's say it
was brian he goes
now listen i think this brian i think
he's more of a i think he's more of a
sean
and adam was like okay and he's like so
so i think is that possible to change
the name from brian and sean i mean i'm
paraphrasing but and was like yeah i
think so he's like all right i'm in oh
my god that was just one note he made
him fight all the way there
but he's there's something really like
um he goes on these
instincts and and
i mean he's got a real great instinct
he's authentic he's authentic yeah
let's read a letter okay let's do it
from
aja jones i hope it's not aha
how do you spell it aja
how would you say that
aja uh i don't know
aja aya uh i it could be okay
subject so far so good
asia could be yeah asha
subject uh i doubt it's aha well when i
maybe she'll explain or they'll explain
okay and then i'll go aha
sorry
requesting another quarantine check-in
new year's eve new year's check-in
question mark smiley face hello long
brothers i'm pleased to report that my
2020 spotify year in review declared
life as short as my most binged podcast
yes and with an old-school wink i like a
good old-school yeah
um i really do love the show the
quarantine check-ins are some of my
favorite episodes that's cool because
it's just us and jerry
and dr dave and dr dave i really enjoy
the relationship you two have as
brothers it's great to hear how support
supportive and sometimes hilariously
critical you are to each other it's a
great balance after a big falling out at
his wedding despite my hardest efforts i
haven't heard from my brother
going on four years now and miss him
very much holy [ __ ]
so i implore you to never take your
relationship for granted ugh i'm sorry
to hear that i'm so curious what
happened
wow at a wedding
oh my god maybe she stood up and said
you know when they do the thing like
does anyone object to this you mean the
brother stood up
yeah or she stood up at her oh yeah
i haven't heard from my brother after a
big fall at his wedding yeah it was at
his wedding
holy [ __ ] i mean what more could it be
do they still do that at weddings
uh if anyone has any objection how do
they say that like i forget but it's
it's if anyone objects
i don't think they do that do they i
haven't heard that
in a while um i don't think they do it
seems
inviting
why would you invite that i know do it
before the wedding
yeah it's like too late they're already
at the altar
maybe that's what it was though or they
got drunk and fell on the wedding cake
who knows okay i'm curious aren't you
god i'm curious i'm curious um
can you write back um i know and then
back to the letter i know dark turn you
turning now
[ __ ] i really want to know i'm very
fortunate to have a great group of
friends in my life who are so creative
and adventurous there's a particular
group that are that are people i've
known since high school and are all
spread around the globe now living out
all kinds of different lives not sharing
a belly laugh when everyone's together
is unheard of with that being said these
maniacs tend to be pretty twisted at
times and after playing many games of
would you rather over the years here are
a few of my favorites for you both oh
boy yeah i think these are going to be
good number one would you rather a
have a force
yep
have a foreskin for a neck that you have
to pull down every time you talk oh
god
or
um or b
be locked in a room for four years with
nothing but yourself you'd be kept alive
by means which are tbd but will keep you
alert and alive oh my god holy [ __ ] i'd
rather the foreskin neck
four years four years a long time two
two years i'd be different
four years i think two years would be
hard four years it's not just the years
you lose but i think you'd start to
lose your mind being solitary
i don't think you could ever recover
from that or i couldn't you'd have to
pull it down every time i'm assuming you
could breathe yeah yeah you can i think
um you'd be kept alive by means no no i
mean with the force oh oh oh yeah yeah
yeah you know
you'd be like pulling it down imagine
foreskin up to the top of my head right
now i'm thinking about that imagine it
yeah
i wouldn't it's crazy to do
just to mop
into foreskin so i'd have to ah so would
i i'd go like this you know i never
thought i'd hear you say that sentence
i'd be breathing into foreskin
um
yeah oh god well you wouldn't need a
mask during the could you pull it down
and just pin it down would you need a
mask um that's a good question could you
clothespin it
uh that's horrible but i guess i would
pick that as long as i could breathe pin
it down
no uh that can't be part of it like have
an operation just to sew it to the rest
and just have this floppy you can't have
a brush
have like the best moyle in the world
operate on you um a giant moyle yeah
yeah
no that's
that's a great one though
number two would you rather a have to
drink hot milk every time you're thirsty
slash every time you drink ever
oof or b
slip out an incredibly loud fart every
time you laugh even if it's a small
giggle you never be able to hide it from
jerry o'connell winky face b that i
don't hide my farts from jerry you don't
no
i wouldn't if i had to fart around him
um
easy that i'm not a big laugher to begin
with
and and it was just true easily you
trained me not to laugh oh that would
suck though i laugh a lot
i find a lot of things funny but
yeah you're not a lot out loud you're
not a hello
no that can be
but it's not it's not easy i have to
drink hot milk
i don't want to drink hot milk every
time but that
satisfy your thirst does that satiate
your thirst satiate it would it's it's
mostly water
it would just be really gross every time
you're thirsty every time you drink ever
i like drinking too that means you
wouldn't be able to drink any anything
else seltzer water i couldn't see even
if i couldn't control my laughter even
if i was like i'm trying to think of the
biggest laugher i know like uh
who's a big laugher
who's like a famous uh who laughs a lot
um like uh fran drescher yeah
yeah she's a good laugher i would i
wouldn't care so i fart all the time and
people know i'm farting like i would
make that deal you would yes to not to
only you have to drink hot milk see it's
different for you it's a lot of these
are different because you already have a
girlfriend you have a dozen partners
well i'm thinking about going on a date
imagine not laughing on a date or every
time you laugh before imagine ordering
hot milk on a date
that's that's less embarrassing you
would have to give a disclaimer say i
that um
that now i'm cursed so i have to um fart
every time i curse me
um
great questions though that's a tough
one okay also one last solo question if
you were to die and become a ghost and
were cursed to have to choose to haunt a
place for the rest of eternity what
would it be you know he's really like on
um i feel like we could be friends with
this guy wait sorry i spaced out for a
second we have what were you thinking of
i was thinking about drinking milk
it's not bad remember when we used to
have those steamers gross i'm sorry
i wonder if people know what cleveland
steamer is i think people do you think
how many what percentage of
to this yeah
i know what a cleveland steamer is 35
40. do you think mom does no do you
think she's listening
probably mcconaughey is listening
probably not
but you think you know sort of
cleveland's name yeah yeah he probably
knows cool ones that we've never even
heard of
like uh like a natural one
like like a nashville show tune
uh okay what's what can you sorry can
you repeat the last part all right so
it's this if you were to die
if you were to die and become a ghost
and were cursed to have to choose to
haunt a place for the rest of eternity
what would it be oh a place yeah one
place
um i'd probably say like um
the us senate florida
or the oval office or something i think
it'd be fun the oval office you get it'd
be so boring but it would be fun to
disrupt the decorum oh
yeah i guess it would be fun because
it's such a proper place that's a good
question
where else would you pick that's true
now i'm thinking about it it's like god
that you'd have to pick the funnest
place in like the playboy mansion
no that wouldn't be fun to be a ghost
it's fun to be alive there
that's stupid it would be frustrating
that's true
uh and also i don't think it exists
anymore oh yeah um
that's a good question god damn that's
tough
wow
um
maybe maybe madison square garden you
get to see a lot of like shows disrupt
games um you don't necessarily disrupt
them see i think i'm i have a more
mischievous ghost take thing well he
says cursed have to choose to haunt he
says haunt a place yeah but you can fun
haunt something yeah yeah
i would that'd be fun to change the
course of a game or to
like make bon jovi mess up i wouldn't
make a joke
against spongebob no that was a bad
choice bon jovi or like
sorry bond sorry bond if you're
listening what do you call bon jovi john
john john john bonchov that's his last
time by the way he i saw him recently in
a thing
that's right well i was thinking when we
were kids his name dan's name was bon
jovi his name isn't bond no i know toby
i forgot that got me laughing yeah
that's true you would be farting right
now really loud if that were and i
wouldn't care because it's just me but
if you're on all the people listening
mcconaughey if you were in a room with
mcconaughey you wouldn't want to blow a
big fart in front of you i wouldn't care
he'd laugh at it i bet hey yeah that's
cool not cool i'd be like
nobody say to a fart
whoa oh someone let the someone let the
horn section out early or something can
someone open a window please no he
wouldn't shame you you really he
wouldn't make you feel bad he'd be like
he'd celebrate it in a fun way
he'd be like oh wow how long have you
been playing in the horn section of the
no he wouldn't fart hormones oh god
yeah he would come up with a really dumb
puppy
you know i uh
god i so many other things i wanted to
ask him so curious about
all the things that like
in his kids and about maybe he'll run
into him in austin
is that the end of the letter yeah sorry
um
it's such a good question i would shoot
i would haunt madison square garden okay
and now i'm picturing what makani would
say to your fart
i just want to like know how he that's
why it's so fun to hear him respond to
like kind of more mundane things like
it's not a bad lightning round question
in general how would you respond to a
farm if you were at a dinner party and
someone loudly farted how would you what
would you say that's a great question
what would you say
somebody depends on the dinner it
depends
back the letter happy new year to you
both i hope you both are in great
spirits warmly
oh [ __ ]
what
warmly aja in princes
pronounced like steely dan's song asia
that's a steely dance song album
oh it is
album no you don't no sorry to shame you
great letter thank you such fun would
you rathers
um
and and
great show
if i do say so
myself that was a hell of a show thank
you to asia and if you guys would like
to write in and be the next asia and
have justin butch your name
our email address is life is short
wondery.com
and thank you to our esteemed guest
matthew mcconaughey
that's what i like about these podcast
episodes man i get older and they stay
the same age
yes they do thank you to everyone who's
listening out there and if matthew is
listening apologies apology
you know that was one of the first
like celebrity uh i mean everyone so
many people do that impression but
that's a perfect example of how
impressions for me personally are all
about celebrating the person i i
pretty much
only do impressions of people that i
really admire
because i hear them a lot and i'm
attuned to their
voices matthew all right um
so we'll see you next week
yeah life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it's produced and co-hosted by you
christian long as well as megan monaco
and a senior producer on this one is
michelle maesh lance getting their hands
on the audio engineering job is one
sergio enriquez executive producers are
marshall louis and ernan lopez four
alright i'll wander y'all
wondering riveting yeah you were into it
huh really
he tells a good story yeah he really
does i want to find out about more about
those people
about the australians yeah what freaks
i thought australians were so kind of
level-headed and you know friendly and
all of them
yeah entire continent
i know but i always got the feeling that
you turn that down
i think a lot of them are but he just
happened to be in this family
he tells a good story though doesn't he
he sure does
you